Madonna is with us Radames in Illinois
IRA Donna how are you hello how are you
better than I deserve how can I help I
was coming today because near my husband
we are behind on our mortgage like
$7,000 behind we got a lot of credit
card ed and we don't have a budget and I
want to start paying the bills off I
don't know where to start I know I need
to have to have a budget I'm getting
behind $7,000 on your house I had got in
a payday loan and it was it was started
out to be just $2,500 and it turned out
to be five thousand all we got was 25
and I wound up trying to pay that back
because they was only every other week
so I was paying them paying and paying
them into I just found Excel I'll just
take the money I said of paying the
mortgage and paid him off for five
thousand
what's your house worth about a hundred
and last time I looked online it's been
a while about a hundred and thirty well
it's like a hundred between 100 125 but
we steal almost 100 as well okay and how
many months behind are you today as of
today three of the mortgages the
mortgage is sixteen hundred okay three
months behind
what's your household income I bring
home every month I mean every two weeks
I get me every week I get paid I get
paid about 700 a week and my husband
it's about 1200 every two weeks so we
probably both make around about 35 40
you know so that this house payments are
very very tough to make even if you were
current well if I was current no yeah
they would yeah I mean you got about
$4,000 a month coming in you got 1600 on
our house payment yeah that's tough
that's part of your problem how much
your car payments um one of them is for
and the other one is four hundred and
other that's 425 time yeah by the time
you pay your car payments in your house
panel you don't have my left not really
a lot no no I'm like none that's 800 and
1600
right is $2,600 in your take-home pays
about four thousand this is what yeah so
you've got a bunch of stuff you can't
afford so something's going to leave
you're either going to cause it to leave
on purpose or they're going to take it
and you need to decide very very quickly
what it is if I were in your shoes I
would stop paying all bills I would sell
both cars immediately even though we
have them to count like even though
they're not paid how could we get rid of
them you'd have to sell them for what
they're worth or cover the difference
with a loan but you've got two four
hundred dollar car payments that are
completely out of line the house is
probably out of line but you can try to
save it you're not gonna be able to save
it and keep the cars you're not going to
be able to keep the cars and and and and
you know if you keep the cars you're
going to let the house go so if
something's gonna go and you got the
side pretty quick because you don't have
enough math room in this to make a turn
you jammed up in the corner kiddo
mathematically hang on I'm gonna have
Laura pick up and see if we can hook you
up with one of our coaches in the local
area there that can help you avoid the
foreclosure it can be done but you're
gonna take some radical steps your kiddo
you painted yourself into a corner
you're getting paint on your feet it's
just no matter what color it is